questions au gouvernement la parole et
au président bernard accoyer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis un an l'italie a créé trois cent
mille emplois
l'espagne cinq cent mille chaque mois la
grande bretagne créer cent mille emplois
en 2015
la quasi totalité des pays européens ont
fait baisser fortement le chômage
al'inverse en france depuis l'élection
de françois hollande on compte un
million cent mille chômeurs de plus
toutes catégories confondues
la france est devenue le seul pays
d'europe où l'on a peur d'embaucher peur
d'embaucher dans les grandes entreprises
peur d'embaucher dans les pme peur
d'embauchés dans les tpe avec l'avant
projet s'il vous plaît de loi travail
transmis au conseil d'état
votre gouvernement prévoyait des mesures
propres à lever quelques freins al
embauche
mais sous la pression de la gauche
protestataire et de ses relais syndicats
et organisations étudiantes politisé
après votre reculade
il ne reste plus rien de ces bonnes
intentions une fois de plus vous aurez
réussi le tour de force de transformer
un texte pro entreprise en un texte anti
emploi anti compétitivité anti
attractivité anti pme avec de surcroît 4
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires non financées alors
monsieur premier ministre alors qu'il y
à un mois vous étiez prêt allez je vous
cite jusqu'au bout après les
renoncements d'hier quels seront vos
renoncement demain pour obtenir le
soutien de votre majorité
merci monsieur accoyer la parole est à
madame myriam el khomri ministre du
travail de l'emploi la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
monsieur le député
j'ai un bernard acoyer
il est essentiel pour nous de porter
cette réforme
l'enjeu de cette réforme c'est justement
de pouvoir parvenir à un équilibre et de
renforcer la négociation collective au
sein des entreprises pour permettre d
adaptation et améliorer la compétitivité
de notre économie
l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est
également de lever les réticences à
l'embauché notamment cdi parce que en
effet ces bons + 12 utilisateurs des cdi
des cdd de moins d'un mois
au niveau de l'union européenne notre
objectif également et de permettre
d'avoir des nouvelles protections pour
les salariés
on peut pas parler de reculade il s'agit
d'un compromis
est-ce qu'il est pas important
d'entendre défense de notre pays
également pour arriver à un compromis
parce que s'il n'y avait pas de
compromis ça serait le retrait du texte
or la situation que connaît notre pays
il est indispensable d'avancer alors
dites moi ce qui ne vous convient pas
dans ce texte
est ce que c'est parce que nous
précisons les licenciements économiques
est ce que c'est parce que nous donnant
de nouvelles souplesse au sein
d'entreprises par la négociation
parce qu'il nous semble impérative dans
notre pays qu'il faut que nous arrivions
à trouver des nouvelles formes de
régulation sociale
oui il a des divergences il a les
divergences avec certains syndicats sur
ce point précis il ya des divergences de
ma famille politique ce poids précis
mais je reste convaincu que c'est par
des adaptations sur le terrain au plus
près avec leurs représentants les
syndicats et non pas dans l'union un
terrain de l'employeur comme vous le
souhaiter que nous arriverons à trouver
un bon équilibre reculer ce n'est
absolument pas l'objectif de ce projet
loi ce projet loi c'est pour que notre
pays avance parce que oui notre pays a
créé moins d'emplois cayen s'ils vont
aussi nous avions réussi avec le pack de
responsabilité a créé plus d'emplois en
2015 qui en avait avant nous restons
déterminés
merci la parole est aux